Hi guys good evening
very few people have come, let's wait a little
meanwhile, whoever is in the meeting, if you have any questions you can ask
session 7 recording audio is missing
yes, that problem was there, then we have updated it, so now it is not happening again, when did you check last
I also saw that problem around 2 hours ago, then I told the swivel
no, no, that problem was 12 hours back, we have resolved it, check it once
I don't know how much you are following this particular playlist, LLME VALS
so if you are following it on YouTube, then great, otherwise you may have a problem in today's class
but at least if you have read it from the beginning, then it would seem easier
we are waiting a little, just some more people join
Sir, how many classes of LLM Ops will be there or how long will it be complete
when we initially planned in LLM Ops, it is not possible to predict exactly
because this is the first time we are taking this course, so we planned 25 to 30 classes
how many classes have been done so far, I think it has been 8 or 9 classes or more than that
it has been 10, so if we catch up with that speed, then in a month you are taking 8 classes roughly
so 1.5 to 2 more months
as such we are not planning a course separately, but if there is a lot of demand, then we can conduct a small session kind of thing
in 2 to 4 hours we can complete, depends, I have not checked what all things come in it
so we are still 6 or 7 people only, let's wait a little more, 1-2 minutes and then start
I guess the timing is getting an issue, but today is Saturday, we had discussed a lot and kept Saturday
and also I feel that a lot of people are watching these videos in recorded format
live, everyone is not able to attend, I guess
whatever it is, we will again take feedback after this month is over
let's see
is there any other question?
I hope this is not the case, people got confused that there is a class at 8 o'clock
this may be the case
it was mentioned clearly, there is a class from 6 pm on Saturday
and now maybe we have given the integration of the Google Calendar, then
ok, let's wait for a minute or two more, whoever has to come will come, maybe post it on the group
Sufal is not in the chat right now, otherwise I would have told him
maybe he will join
you guys post something, then the class has started
thanks Nidhi
ok, we are not too late, it's 6.02
there will be separate classes for guardrails like LLMA Wales, yes Sumit
after this, there are two more playlists in my mind, one is system design, you can say gen AI system design
and the second is AI security and guardrails, with that, the whole track will be over
after that nothing will be left, then we will move to the builder track where we will learn to train LLMs
who will teach gen AI system design?
it will be between me and Himanshu, it depends on who finishes the course first, if LLM Wales finishes first then I will teach
if LLM ops finishes first then he will teach
he has taught LLM ops, so he is more close to teaching system design
because basically you implement the system design in the ops part
it's like, I gave an example that the planning of the airport, if you want to build an airport in a city, then the planning around it is system design
and on a day to day basis, the operations of running the airport are ML ops or LLM ops
so whoever has studied ML ops or LLM ops, will be able to appreciate system design better because he has already done those things practically
so yeah, but yeah, my plan is that by November, hopefully, before that, we will complete the AI engineering track
that's our goal, so that we will cover the pre-training, data preparation, tokenization, fine-tuning, etc. of the builder side of LLMs
we will cover all that in the first 6 months of the next year
so I would say that our whole offering of campusX will be very holistic
there is machine learning, deep learning, LLM gen. AI, and the building part
so I am just hopeful that we will be able to do this in the next 6-7 months
if possible, can you teach it because trade-offs in all system design is mainly a trade-off one
yeah, I will try, it's a matter of operations, you have to see multiple things and plan accordingly
I would like to teach it because I like it a lot
so let's hope
okay, let's do one thing, it's 6.05, let's start the class
if you have any other questions, I will take them at the end of the session
just tell me, can you see this screen, the one-note screen
okay, fine
so before starting the class, a quick recap of what we were reading
so we were reading the benchmarking of LLMs
we had seen the whole process in the last two last classes
what are the benchmarks and how they are applied for evaluation
then we started reading the benchmarks one by one in the last class
and we targeted first of all on this capability, which is the knowledge capability
and we had seen the whole roadmap of knowledge capability
that when, which benchmark came in the picture and why
and then we started covering the important benchmarks one by one
in the last class, if you remember, we first covered MMLU
then we covered Truthful QA
then we covered AGI Eval
and in the last session, the light went off
and because of that, the session was automatically shut down
so first of all, we have done an improvement
I would like to share, we have ordered a UPS for our wifi
so going forward, it will never happen that the light went off and the class got stuck
unless the light goes off for 6-7 hours, which generally does not happen in our office building
so that problem is solved and we will start today's class from exactly that point
in today's class, we are going to study in two parts
in the first part, we will cover the remaining benchmarks
which would include GPQA, which is on your screen
after that, we will also cover
one is Simple QA
MMLU Pro
and lastly, all of them are HLE
we will cover this and then in the second half of the session, we will study about leaderboards
and I am very happy to tell you that today is the last theoretical class of this course
after this, going forward, all the classes will be highly practical
so just study theory for today, get bored
and then in the next class, we will do things practically
so you will find it a little more interesting
so is the plan clear guys?
where are we now?
and what is the plan of today's class? is it clear?
should we start?
ok, let's start
so let me remove this once, it will be a little difficult to write
so the next benchmark we are going to study is GPQA
the full form of GPQA is very interesting
its full form is Google Proof Question and Answers
and I will tell you the principle behind this
this benchmark came in the picture because
MMLU was saturated
and then people thought that what did we do in MMLU?
we checked the breadth of knowledge
by asking questions around 57 subjects
but those questions were mostly easy
if you go and see that data set yourself, you will realize that the questions are not very difficult
you can also answer
so here some researchers thought that
it is possible that as LLM gets smarter
it will be very easy to answer easy questions for them
so what if rather than checking the breadth of knowledge
what if we check the depth of knowledge?
basically rather than asking simple questions
what if we ask difficult questions?
like really difficult questions
PhD level questions
but the problem is that if you go in depth
then it is not possible to cover a lot of subjects
because obviously expertise is costly in the world
so they thought that rather than going all out in 57 subjects
let's just focus on 3 subjects
which 3 subjects?
physics, chemistry and bio
and we will make a science based benchmark
which will be made with research level PhD questions
and the specialty of these questions is that
if a non-specialist comes from any other domain
then even if he gets Google, we give him 30 minutes of time
then he will not be able to solve even one question
questions of this level will be put in this data set
see everything is written here
it was launched in November 2023 and it was called Google proof
PhD people made this benchmark by adding the hardest questions
of science as in physics, chemistry and biology
and the biggest differentiator of this was that
every question that was put in this data set
was validated by 2 domain experts
so it was not a mistake
and these questions are so difficult
that even if a non-expert comes
and he gets Google access
then he will not be able to solve even one question in 30 minutes
and we call this Google proof
and this is the part of its name
if we tell the current status of this benchmark
now it is 2026 so this benchmark is
near-scientific
so now this benchmark is near-saturation
now the new generation LLMs
which have reasoning capability
and have been trained on more data
now they are going above 80% in this benchmark
so you can say that
in a few years it will be saturated
so here the same lineage is told
that in November 2023 GPQA was released
and the most state of the art model of that time was GPT-4
which could only solve 39% of the questions
of the main data set
after that in 2024
GPT-4O came
which reached 56% in the diamond data set
so there are actually 3 data sets in GPQA
one is the normal one
one is, I don't remember the name
one is the main one
one is the extended one
and one is the diamond one
so in the main one there are
443 questions, in the extended one
there are 546 questions
and in the diamond one there are only 198 questions
so in the extended one
there are all the questions
and then they edited this
so in some questions
they saw errors
so after removing those questions, there were 443 questions left
and in these 443 questions
198 most difficult questions were put in this
diamond data set
so whenever someone says that in GPQA we achieved 63%
or 83%
it means that how much percent they achieved
in the most difficult data set
so here it is written exactly that
in 2024 GPT-4O came
and it scored 56% in the diamond one
then came the O1 of OpenAI
which was a very strong reasoning model of 2024
it achieved 78%
at this point, OpenAI
hired experts and gave them
this data set to solve
so those experts solved 69.7%
or their score came
so at this point OpenAI did a lot of marketing
that we have beaten the PhDs in GPQA
so this was also a big news at that time
then in 2025 when the frontier models became more powerful
then GROCK-4 came which scored almost 87%
and then it felt that
this data set will get saturated
because as I told you that the life cycle
it came close to saturation
so this is pretty much the journey of this data set
if you read about its tasks and data set details
then as I said expert level questions
in biology, physics and chemistry
a typical question looks like this
physics question I guess
particle spin etc. has been discussed
there are 4 options and you have to select the best option
as you can see in most of the knowledge benchmarks
here I have told you that there are 3 subsets
in this entire benchmark, main, extended and diamond
and the task is that you will be given only 4 options
you have to tell the correct answer in one question
and the metric is accuracy obviously
run configuration is the same
zero shot, chain of thought allowed, temperature 0
pass at the rate 1 and tools access is not given
and if we discuss 2 important pointers
that what does this data set not measure
so first of all it does not measure
general graduate knowledge
till now our data sets were targeting
general knowledge, this is strictly
the target benchmark of science
so if a model is scoring very hard
then it is only a representation of this
that that model has absorbed the knowledge
of science very well, the rest is not guaranteed
second open-ended problem solving
this benchmark does not tell you anything
here you are simply selecting one option from the given options
it does not mean that when it will be given an open-ended
question of science then it will give you good results
and lastly here
the reasoning trace is not being evaluated
you may know what reasoning models do
reasoning models internally reason
before giving any answer
so we give them a task pad
and we also give them a token budget
that look we have a token budget, you can think in this much
so internally they think, you may have seen
while using chart GPT, it is written there
that now the model is doing this, now this, now this, we call it reasoning
so the reasoning trace
we are not evaluating it, which basically means
that we are not evaluating this thing that how the model
is reaching the answer, there are many ways to reach the answer
you are directly calculating the right answer
or you are eliminating the wrong options
or you are putting a mark on it
anything can happen, right?
so here we are not validating the correctness of reasoning trace
which basically means that if the model is putting a mark internally
and it is correct then we are giving it marks
so this benchmark does not measure these three things
if we discuss some known issues
or criticisms
then the biggest criticism is that there are very few questions
in comparison to past data sets where we have seen
14000-15000 questions
here there are only 198 questions
so the more the questions decrease
the less your confidence on the result decreases
you had read this in statistics especially in hypothesis testing
so your confidence interval rating is not very
we can say that you cannot trust it that much
so that is one criticism that this benchmark gets
after that here
whenever a model says
or a company says that our model
beat the PhDs on GPQA
then this is not a concrete fact
like when OpenAI hired the PhDs
they scored 69.7 whereas
when the paper was published then they said that the PhDs
which we gave this test, they scored 81.3
so again we do not know how much the PhDs
scored
so if you are creating news around it
then that is not correct
after that contamination like with any other benchmark
here also your contamination
is coming in the picture, it has been 2-3 years now
so now its questions
are also going in the training data set of your model
and we have discussed that
it is only catering to 3 domains
physics, chemistry, biology
so it is not testing the overall graduate level knowledge
so this was the biggest criticism of this
so I hope you understood GPQA roughly
the core idea is that we are still testing the breadth of knowledge
we are taking a new angle and testing the depth of knowledge
and this benchmark does exactly this
so this is complete
if you have any questions then you can ask
I have opened the chat
after this we have to discuss 3 more
it will take 10-10 minutes max
what is the reason for getting benchmark testing obsolete
is this because key is available on web or really reasoning capability
both the reasons are there
like I said before
the benchmark is not available on web
so you have to get a benchmark
and then you have to get a benchmark
both the reasons are there
as the next models are coming
their capability is increasing
so they will perform better
but at the same time if it comes in training data
then memorization is done
so both the reasons are there
let's move ahead in the discussion
let's talk about MM LU PRO
it is an upgrade
directly on the very famous
MM LU benchmark
let me tell you the reasoning behind this
as I said, MM LU was saturated
and as it was saturated
researchers started to think in different directions
GPQEVs started to think that instead of breadth
they check depth
and instead of benchmarking
they use existing exams as benchmarks
so some researchers said that MM LU is a good benchmark
if it is saturated
then what if we improve it or its problems
and from this thought process MM LU PRO came
so basically whatever problems were there in MM LU
MM LU PRO tried to solve them
they basically said that if a product is good
then the next iteration of that product should be good
that's the main thinking behind this benchmark
so the tagline of this MM LU PRO
is simply MM LU Rebuilt
to fix its flaws
so whatever problems were there in MM LU
they tried to solve them
let me tell you what things were solved
the first change is that instead of giving 4 options
in MCQ we give 10 options
what will happen if we give 10 options
according to you
can you tell me if you are going to give one exam
let's say IIT JEE or whatever other exams
and instead of 4 options you get 10 options
in every question
so will your exam become more difficult or easy
or I guess you can understand
so we have given such exams
and we try to eliminate options
and reach the right option
so when you have 4 options then elimination is easy
you have to eliminate 3 and reach 1
when you have 10 then it will become very difficult
so basically to increase the complexity
researchers gave 10 options instead of 4
second, what they did is
they removed the most basic questions
and the noisy questions
from MM LU and instead of them
added reasoning based questions
I will show you an example after a while
but what did they do? MM LU was famous for asking
basic factuality based questions
but they removed them and replaced them with
a little complex reasoning based questions
so what did they do? They said that they will not focus on 57 subjects
because if you are going to focus on 57 subjects
then you are focusing on some subjects more
and less on some subjects, so that is not good
so they selected only 14 broad categories
and in these 14 categories they added questions
and in every category they added enough questions
so that no category under represents
so these were the 3 major changes
and these changes were beneficial
the proof of this is that
the models that could do reasoning
they saw that they are 20 points ahead
of non reasoning models
which actually shows that
there is a need to think in this data set
earlier without thinking you could only
recall factuality and bring good numbers
but now in this exam
you will have to think in this benchmark
so this benchmark favored reasoning models
in that sense
if we look at its lineage it is very simple
in 2020 MM LU came, XBOB was saturated
in 2024 2 papers came
one was called MM LU Redux and the other
one was called MM LU Pro
Redux is not actually a benchmark
I was confused earlier, I will tell you upfront
this is not a benchmark, this is a paper
which showed that
there are many problems in MM LU
and the biggest problem is that around 6-8%
questions are incorrect
incorrect in the sense
either the answer is not given properly
or the answer is not being said properly
so these researchers found this finding
so this is how we found out that
no one can score 100% on MM LU
people were thinking that we are reaching
90-92 but no one is able to go on it
so we found out the reason when MM LU Redux paper came
so after this we understood that
this benchmark is saturated and now we have to do something new
that's when MM LU Pro paper came
and they made all these changes
which I have told you above
so if you talk about the current status of MM LU Pro
it came in 2024, now it is running in 2026
and now it is also nearing saturation
so people are now scoring around 80-90
if we talk about its task and data set details
so here there are 12000 questions
14000 questions were in MM LU
instead of 57 there are 14 disciplines
here is a typical question
now look at the options
A, B, C, there are up to J options
now this question is not a
factuality recall
here you need facts as in knowledge
but at the same time you have to reason
so this is what I told you that these questions are added
task is simple
you have to answer in quiz format
so core metric is again accuracy
just like other benchmarks
so you can't use tools
like 5 shot, COT, temperature 0, pass at the rate 1
you can't use tools
if we talk about what benchmark
this benchmark can't measure
like other benchmarks, it doesn't measure open-ended generation
here you have to select one of the options
but you are not generating
so we are not able to check the generation capabilities
so here we are not measuring the correctness of reasoning trace
we are just measuring the end answer
and lastly we are not checking the calibration
calibration came in the last class as well
calibration simply means
does a model know that
it doesn't know the answer
this is calibration, remember it is written here
no test of whether a model knows what it doesn't know
if a model doesn't know that it doesn't know the answer
then it will hallucinate and give some answer
but those who know that they don't know this
instead of hallucinating, they will clearly say
I am not sure about the answer
so here you don't check the calibration
so these are 2-3 things
criticisms, known issues, there is no human baseline here
all the benchmarks we have discussed so far
in these papers, human baseline was mentioned
in this paper, no human baseline was mentioned
so we don't have any comparison threshold
where humans are operating, where models are going
nothing like that
approaching saturation because now frontier models
have advanced and there is a contamination issue in this
so yeah, very close to saturation
and here
reasoning models score very well
this is also a criticism
MMLU is a benchmark that you can apply to any kind of model
but here reasoning models have unfair advantages
because explicitly such questions are put where reasoning will help
and again source contamination list
because many questions have been raised from your public stem problem
so there is a good chance that
contamination is there, now think for yourself
you don't think that you have been raised from HC Verma
or from any similar physics book
so such questions or similar questions
are publicly available to you
and that is one of the reasons why in 2024
this benchmark is going to be saturated
so yeah, nothing new
an old thing that was good, an attempt to improve it
this attempt lasted for 2 years
so now forward, this will also be saturated
so yeah, this was the second benchmark of the day
let me know if you have any doubts related to this
if you have no doubts, then just write clear
or something else like that
then we will move forward
can you explain the first criticism point again
just wait
what was it
no human baseline
so till now you will see that any paper or benchmark
that we discussed, a human baseline is told from the beginning
it comes in the research paper
so here like in GPQMA, it is written here
that
somewhere down here
whatever you read
maybe 68% or 78%
81%
yes, it is written here
true against the pool, short of papers
81.3, so it was mentioned in the paper
that in this particular benchmark
humans performance is 81.3, this is called human baseline
so once you get the human baseline
then all the models try to reach it
this makes it clear that in this particular aspect
in this particular problem benchmark
models are reaching humans
in MMLU Pro
there was no such human baseline in the paper
they did not give it, whereas in the original
MMLU, people criticized
that the benchmark you have designed
why are you not carrying the core philosophy
that's it, it is not a big point
shall we move to the next
ok
the next benchmark is
interesting, in the sense that
the benchmarks we discussed earlier are different
in two aspects
we will discuss both the aspects, before that
I will tell you the story of this benchmark
so if you remember, we discussed
that everything started from MMLU
one branch came out of it
that take the exam like humans
quickly tell us which benchmark
was it, quick quiz in between
just to check if you are retaining or not
will anyone tell us
which benchmark was it that said
rather than creating new benchmarks
why don't you use existing exams to check
model intelligence or their knowledge
which was it
come on, no one remembers
AGI well
then who asked questions about reliability
we also read a benchmark
which said that answers are available
we are also measuring it, but is the answer
right or hallucination, which way did it go
truthful QA
then who went the way of depth
we just read GPQA
and who went to fix MMLU
MMLU Pro
right, this is the map so far
now, simple QA
where does it fit, I will tell you
it fits here, when truthful QA
was saturated, then this reliability question
was in the picture, that the model that is answering
is correct, it is okay to check its knowledge
but it is so right
it is truthful, that is also important
so, truthful QA was replaced
simple QA
and the best thing about simple QA is that
it is very simple, its name is also its work
but even then it is a very difficult
to crack benchmark for LLMs
it is still active
maybe this is the first benchmark
which I am saying that it is still active
it is not saturated, it is not near saturation
it is active
so now I will tell you what is the scene, what does this benchmark do
so in this benchmark you get
a dataset of 4000 plus short fact seeking questions
simple questions we ask
that who got the Nobel prize in this field
in a particular year, there are such questions
the interesting thing is that in this dataset
you are not given options
basically this is not a MCQ dataset
this is a short answer writing
kind of benchmark, you have to write the answer
and tell it, so automatically
the questions are more difficult, think and tell
are subjective exams more difficult
or MCQ based exams, what do you personally think
just write in the chat
which exam would you prefer
I know no one wants to give exams but there are two options
one is MCQ and one is writing
you have to write the answers completely, so which one is more difficult
I guess a lot of people would agree that
subjective exams are more difficult
that is why LLMs also feel the same thing
that when they are given a subjective exam
then it is difficult to answer for them
and this is one of the major strengths of simple QA
second, this dataset
this benchmark not only measures
accuracy, it also
measures calibration
I explained calibration a little while ago
and he knows that he does not know the answer
this is also known in this dataset
in this benchmark because
we measure three things here
after seeing an answer we measure
is it correct
or is it incorrect or
the model said pass, I don't want to answer
we also measure this thing
and because of this thing
we can find out
whether the model knows or not that he does not know the answer
I hope I am able to explain, see here it is written exactly
and 4,326 questions
short fact seeking questions
and how all these questions have been made
this is a set of questions in which
GPT-4 failed in answering
so these 4000 questions are such questions
which at that time
state of the art model could not answer
that is why these difficult questions will be considered
OpenAI launched it in 2024
and the best thing about it
as I discussed, here you do not get options
so you have to write the answer
you have to generate the answer and this is the reason
that the same model which scored 88% in MMLU
could only score 40% in simple QA
and at this point its status is
that it is active and now
there is no chance that it will saturate
design insight is that
there are two benchmarks in this
there are two benchmarks in this one benchmark
one obviously tells whether the answer is correct or wrong
but there is a third category
not attempted
which tells us how humble the model is
it is not ignorant
when the model says that I don't know
then we understand that
it is not hallucinating
it is confident about its abilities
so the philosophy of this paper is
that get as many questions correct
as possible while not attempting
the ones you are not confident about
this benchmark tells us this
so factuality plus calibration
these two things are testing
in simple QA
let's talk about history and lineage
it came in 2014, GPT 4.0 at that time
it scored 38% in the QA model
O1 preview scored 42%
till February 2025
it scored 4.5 at 62.5
so yeah, this benchmark is still there
we can say that it will be active
for maybe one or two more years
we discussed the data set
we discussed the design criteria
the correct answer is
just one second
hallucinated answer is this
incorrect answer basically
and the third answer
the model can say that I am not certain
who won that year
these are the three possibilities
task is very simple
you have to answer the question
here is a LLM judge
who will judge the answer
and will put it in one of the three categories
correct or wrong, it didn't attempt
and what is the score?
here are three metrics
the headline metric is correct
out of all questions, how many answers were correct
the second metric is
correct given attempted
it tells accuracy among only attempted questions
so 4300 questions
the model attempted 3500
so how many were correct in these 3500
and the third is F score
which is the harmonic mean of this one and this one
so the harmonic mean is
it tells us about both the things
how good is its factuality and how good is its calibration
so this is the difference
between this particular benchmark and all the other benchmarks
that we discussed before
here we are checking the calibration
run config is nothing different
and if we want to discuss
so although it measures
factuality, but it is short form
factuality
who won that award that year, it is a two word answer
so we are checking this but we are not checking
long form factuality, how good will this model be
we can't tell with the help of this benchmark
secondly we are checking that
how well the model is calibrating
but again we can't guarantee
that when we make a rag chartboard with the help of that model
and give it some documents
then it will hallucinate or not
we are not testing that here so this should be clear
also everyday factual reliability
is not there so as I said
when was this data set made or how it was made
every question is such a question on which
we made this data set of
these questions
so these are kind of rare questions
these are not normal daily questions
so we have created a data set that is
extraordinary
we have made it with different type of questions
so based on the performance on that
we can't tell how the everyday recall or factuality will be
because of this benchmark
if we talk about known issues and criticisms
so since we have put an LLM grader here
basically an LLM as a judge to evaluate the answer
so obviously over the years
this LLM as the judge will improve
new models will come
so the performance of the LLM judge we are using today
can't be compared with the LLM judge 2 years ago
because obviously models are improving
on a daily basis so
because of this we can't compare the benchmark
with the results of 2 years ago
next is answer's staleness
what is this? it's simple meaning
like there is a question of your data set
what question can it be
who is the
ranked 1
rugby player of the world
let's say now this data set was made in 2024
so in 2024 let's say ABC was
the player name but in 2026
by removing ABC XYZ became the
ranked 1 player, this can happen right?
so the problem of answer's staleness is that many answers
are not the same as they were 2 years ago
so this is the benchmark
and lastly
adversarial against GPT-4 selection bias
here it is said that
this whole data set benchmark is made from the questions
on which GPT-4 failed
so there is an adversarial bias against GPT-4 models
so now this can be beneficial for other models
and can be harmful
there is no treatment to all the models
so that is one of the criticisms that comes against this benchmark
but despite that simple QA is
a very respectable benchmark
and if someone is able to score
on this benchmark then it is considered very good
so even though its name is simple QA
but it's a great benchmark to have
it helps you a lot in catching hallucinations
let me know if you have any doubts in simple QA
then after this
we will discuss a last
benchmark which is the daddy of all these
its name is HLE
humanities last exam
a question has come
if the question is fact based right
like Nobel prize winner in specific year and all
so here you have to keep one thing in mind
when we say that we put the data of the internet
of the world
in a model
then we can say that
we can put the data of the internet
of the world
so we can say that
we can put the data of the internet
so if we put the data of the internet of the world
in training a model
it does not guarantee that it will absorb the data of the internet
of the world
there are many stages of cleaning of the data
there is a good chance that
the fact or piece of knowledge does not reach the model
basically the model cannot absorb it
and if we talk about the other
the core philosophy of this
is that it is checking the truthfulness
of a model
that does it know that or not
that it does not know the answer
this is the main ask of this benchmark
it is not checking the fact or knowledge
knowledge based questions are being asked
but they are being asked so that we can judge
whether there is an idea or not
this is the main idea of this benchmark
I hope I answered your question
is there any other question at this point?
if not then write it clearly
then we will move to the last benchmark
under knowledge capability
yes that is what I am saying
it is all about calibration
ok
so let's go
let's discuss HLE
HLE is like
a very dramatic name
humanities last exam
it sounds a bit heavy
let me tell you the thought process behind it
the thought process behind humanities last exam
the thought process behind it is very simple
what HLE did
it absorbed the ideas of the previous benchmark
so it took the breadth from MMLU
it took the depth from GPQA
and basically
it created a depth cross breadth
which has 2500 questions
all of them are expert written questions
across 100 plus subjects
from classics to rocket engineering
and each filtered to stump frontier models
and it is a thesis in which frontier models are not able to answer
so that is the main idea behind HLE
and its name HLE is because
its name is because
that the name is a thesis not marketing
if models saturate a broad expert level
unambiguous answer exam this hard
then closed ended question answering
there is nothing left to measure
and evaluation must move to open ended
basic idea is that the researchers
who published this benchmark said that
if a model is cracking such a difficult benchmark
which can handle both depth and breadth
then there is nothing left to check
after this we should move forward
and then we should focus on how the agentic
tasks and open ended tasks are handling
and that is why they kept the name
humanities last exam
current status of this benchmark is that
it is active in fact
even a few days back all the models
which gave this benchmark test
were operating in single digit
after the release of the G3 pro
it reached 38% finally
so here it is told
how this data set was made
HLE takes the same expert authored
failure filtered recipe like GPQA
like GPQA was made to bring depth
and it increases it at scale
here 1000 experts
50 countries
made this 2500 questions
spreading 100 plus subjects
this is a massive effort generally benchmarks
comes from a small research group
this is like a proper world wide people
working on a project and then that project was made
so DPQA where only
physics, chemistry and biology was deep
across the whole map of human expertise
humans have knowledge about all the fields
all the fields have the
deepest questions of accumulation
and that is why this name was given
here one more thing was done
that the research institute
which has made this benchmark
they have held its private
test set
so a public set of 2500 questions
and a private set which is not available on the internet
is only with this institute
and they have kept it with them so that they can always
test a new model on that test set
and they can give results so this work was done
to stop contamination
also here one more new thing is that this model
not only does this benchmark test accuracy
it also tests calibration
whenever you send a question to the model
you also tell it that
how confident were you to answer this question
so the model tells itself that
I am 80% confident, I am 75% confident
so not only accuracy is being measured here
also the confidence score is being used
so you can tell how much the model knows about itself
or how truthful it is
let's talk about the lineage
it came in January 2025
in 2025 GROK 4 went on 24, GPT 5 on 25
Gemini went on 38
and in 2026 it is still active
infact even now knowledge and reasoning test
and maths is also a domain
so it is still the top benchmark
if we want to tell the new models that
our knowledge, reasoning and maths is very strong
then they will tell you the score of this benchmark
we have discussed the detail of the data set
this is a sample question by the way
you can't see it by pausing, it is live class
but in future when you will see the recording you can pause and see
the main USP is breadth times depth
people either have breadth of knowledge or depth of knowledge
I don't think there will be a person in the world
who has breadth and depth both
there will be no PhD who has PhD in 100 subjects
you can do PhD in only one subject
because depth takes time
so the same problem was thrown in front of the model
that you can get breadth, you can get depth in less subjects
but we are asking you that you get depth in 100 subjects
whether you get depth or not
here also you take test in two formats
80% questions are short answer questions
where you have to type the answer
generate it and 20% questions are MCQ based
it is a mixture but there are more questions
which you have to type and generate
also 10% of all the questions
are multimodal
which basically means that in these questions
a photo has been shown, in fact I will show you
if you go to HLE's homepage
this is it, so you will see in this
I want the leaderboard
I want the benchmark
so in this you will notice that in some questions
there are images like this
this is image, now this question has been asked
so this is also a new thing, so far
the benchmarks we have discussed
there was only textual data, here in 10% questions
there is also vision based data
so many models who do not have vision capabilities
they will basically score on 90% data set
so it is important to see this in the result
you cannot use these tools
as we have seen earlier
and core metric is accuracy
but you focus on calibration
it is written here
there is an internal mechanism
where they draw the root mean square between the confidence of the model
and the correctness of the model
again it was very technical, I could not give much time
so you will understand
this was the run configuration
and what we do not measure, we will discuss
open-ended and agentic problem solving
because this is close-ended
we are not measuring everyday usefulness
because as we have discussed there are very expert level questions
and we are not testing vision and multilingual capabilities
I mean vision is being tested
because 10% data is there
multilingual capabilities are not being tested
because this data set is in English only
known issues are that
there is a dispute in some questions answers
initially it was a data set of 3000 questions
due to those disputes only 2500 questions were left
LLM as a judge is used here
to grade the answers
it is the same in that
grading error happens
if you use LLM as a judge
it is not reliable, it can vary the result
and lastly
failure, filter, selection bias, magnified
so as I said this data set is also made
from those questions on which the frontier models of 2024
were failing in answering
there is a selection bias in this data set
and it does not represent the general knowledge
which people ask on a day to day basis
so in that sense there is a bias in the data set
but the summary is that
this is like the most powerful test
that you can give to an LLM
in order to test its knowledge, reasoning
and mathematical capabilities
so if someone asks you today
what is the state of the art benchmark
without a doubt one can say
actually is that benchmark, humanities last exam
with that
our discussion concludes
we covered everything about the knowledge
all the important benchmarks
in detail, I know it might have seemed a little boring
because there is a lot of theory
but again if you understand like a story
then we absorbed a lot in the last 1.5 hours
now an important point
the problem is this
that we have only discussed one capability
which is knowledge capability
apart from this there are 7 more capabilities
just like this, so we have reasoning
maths and reasoning can be clubbed together
but then we have coding, very important capability
we have instruction following, very underrated
we have vision and multimodal capabilities
we have long context
again a very understated
and one more thing I am forgetting, safety
again very important, safety and alignment
now the problem is that in one capability
we took around 1.5 hours
and in other capabilities also there is a similar journey
there are many benchmarks and why every benchmark
why did the previous one come out, what is new in the new one
so all have stories
so for me at this point it's not possible
to cover everything
but all this seems kind of important to me
because when you know all this
the 1.5 hours you have to study
this 1.5 hours study will take you up
because you got a little more knowledge about the field
everyone will study basic things
how to make a rack, how to evaluate it
but a proper knowledge is how the field evolved
in the last 3-4 years, this kind of
subconscious knowledge builds about a field
so I feel in that sense this is all important
so I have planned this for you
that Rupinder, I guess you must have met Rupinder
I have given Rupinder clear instructions
that in the next 2 weeks
all these remaining
capabilities
will record lectures
so around 8-10 hours of content
in which he will use the same format
he will tell you the story of how the field evolved
and then he will discuss the benchmarks with you
and we will add that in your dashboard
unfortunately we won't be able to give this to the YouTube audience
so this is exclusive to you guys
and again if you want to study then you can
if you don't want to study then you can leave
we are giving you a shorter solution
and this shorter solution is for you as well as the YouTube people
so this is the process of making this
I will share the URL with you
this is the URL
here we are documenting
our entire teaching journey
so we have covered 23 benchmarks
on this website
7 of these are the ones I have taught you
apart from that we have added reasoning and maths
so you can go to the website and we have categorized
which are active, which are nearing saturation
which are saturated and which are deprecated
and you can filter out from here as well
and everything is explained in detail
I have shown this in the last class as well
but now we have deployed it as well
and added more benchmarks
and in the next 2 weeks we will add more additional
so if you don't want to
spend your time watching long lectures
about these benchmarks
what you can do is you can simply go to this website
and you can read about whatever benchmarks
you would like to learn about
so this is the solution, I hope you are understanding
and you are understanding my reasoning as well
why I can't teach you everything because it will take a lot of time
so this is the whole discussion, is it clear?
you can bookmark this url
benchwiki.versal.app
you will get to see it here
so I have taught you one whole month
now you can figure out the rest of it yourself
there is only one problem on the website
I have taught you a lot about this
but the journey I have taught you
you won't get it on the website
the journey I have taught you
you will have to see Rupinder's lectures
you can do a detailed study about any benchmark
there is no problem
so guys if you have any other question
then ask, I need a 5 minutes break
I am getting a call
so let's resume in 5 minutes
next we have to study about LLM leaderboards
so give me 5 minutes
I will make sure audio and video are off
and I will come back in 5 minutes
meanwhile if you have any questions, type them
thank you
oh yeah guys
let me quickly check
is there any question
Aman it's actually straightforward
there is not much to think about
I was also curious how it works
but you can think that
hallucination and lying are two different things
don't think that
if I am telling him
how confident you are, he will lie
that is not hallucination
models are not deceived
so when we tell him to tell us his confidence score
then they can actually tell you
what is the confidence score according to them
at least this is what I tried to understand in the research paper
the exact mechanism
of understanding this
is how the model is telling its confidence score
if you want to understand that
then maybe it will need a plot session
but yeah you can ask a model
type a question on chartgpt and ask it
how confident are you
then ask a more difficult question and ask how confident are you
and that number will generally seem logical
that his confidence score is decreasing
so something comes out of his weight and parameters
that is also a knowledge
so guys now we are moving to the next topic
and it is also important to read this topic
because we are reading everything step by step
so it will not be right to leave this topic
the name of this topic is
LLM leader votes
so since we have read about benchmarks
so it makes sense
that we read about leader votes too
because they are highly connected
so let's move on to the topic
it is a very cute little topic
nothing complex
but you will understand
you already know it but if you understand it
then you will feel good
will anyone tell before starting
what are leader votes LLM leader votes
have you seen somewhere
if you have seen then tell me the name of a leader vote that you have seen or use
in your company or in your day to day work
can anyone tell me
what are leader votes
anyone
it is written in front
it is very simple
what are benchmarks
benchmarks are an exam to test LLMs in a particular aspect
so it is an exam
after giving the exam result comes
you will publish the result somewhere
somewhere you will show
that place is your leader votes
like leader votes in your school
who tell who topped or whatever
so here is a simple definition
and LLM leader vote is a public ranking
that shows how different LLMs
perform on a common set of evaluations
so benchmark result
we show on the leader vote
and leader vote is a single place where we can compare
different models on one benchmark
so that we get an overview
which is the best model in this benchmark
that is the basic idea of a leader vote
why do leader votes exist
one reason I just told you
that we compare models across labs with a common reference
same exam given by all the models
who came top, who came second, who came last
we get to know that from that
who we have to use in our application
second, leader votes also provide trust
generally leader votes are third party
so if Claude himself says that
we scored so much on this benchmark
then you will not trust him that much
because obviously openAI will want more praise for his model
but if a third party comes and says that we have tested Claude
on one exam and also openAI
and these are the results, then you will believe more
because it is a third party, its stakes are not as high
as openAI and Claude
so we have to use that
second, it guides model selection
when you don't have resources to run
evals yourself
you want to make a chart board
which has the capabilities of maths
your students are like this
so obviously you want me to test the evaluation
but is it possible for you
that you can do hundreds of models
and you want to test all of them
its not possible, there are so many models
you have to select one model
so what is your job, that you bring 100 models
and run those evaluations on 100
it will take a lot of money
it will take a lot of time and effort
if someone else is doing it for you, then its easy for you
so you can simply go to the leaderboard
and pick your top 10 and pick your model
so this is the second benefit
third, with the help of this we get to know
that has any benchmark saturated
if a lot of top models
start to cluster around the same score
there is a benchmark that tests knowledge capability
there the score of top 10 LLMs
and its score is between 92-94
so as soon as the clustering started to appear on the LLM leaderboard
we understood that this benchmark is saturating
so that is also a purpose for which people use LLM leaderboards
and the fourth one is also very useful
I have been working on this since 2022
that whenever I have to discover new models
I use LLM leaderboards for that
because generally top 3-4 are the same
Google, OpenAI and Anthropic models
but if you scroll down
10, 12, 15, 20, as soon as they appear
you start seeing new models
and these models are not the best
but they can be useful for your purpose
because they are generally cheaper
so LLM leaderboards help you in discovering new models
if we talk about who uses LLM leaderboards
and what is the purpose of using LLM leaderboards
there are 3-4 stakeholders here
first are AI engineers, people like you and me
who want to make LLM based applications
and we use LLM leaderboards to shortlist
I want to make an application in the maths domain
so I will go to the maths leaderboard
and from there I will select my candidate models
generally you do not select a single model from the leaderboard
you select your own model and then run your evals
and from there you get your best model
which you will use to make an application
so LLM leaderboards help you in filtering
100-5
second is Frontier Labs
they use leaderboards a lot because
first of all they know where they are lying
and where they are existing
so they know if they should release their next models
for example
I am not an open AI, my current model is
GPT 5.5
and in front of me is OPUS 4.8
in a particular benchmark
I saw that the next model I am training
is not even beating OPUS 4.8
so will I release that model?
and people will say that this is worse than OPUS 4.8
which is their previous model
so I have bad marketing
so rather than releasing that iteration
I will go to the next iteration
and then I will release when I see that I am significantly
behind the rest of the leaderboards
and this is actually done
internally they plan and strategize when to release
and where they are lying on the leaderboard of the check
so you must have seen
that some models come on the leaderboard
with hidden names
you must have heard Nano Banana
why is Nano Banana so funny?
because initially when it came it came in stealth mode
in any image leaderboard
and they did not tell that it is a Google model
and they just broke all the benchmarks
so when they saw that it is significantly
beating everyone then they release it
in front of people
so there Google said that Nano Banana is so famous
that it is marketing so let's keep Nano Banana
so leaderboards are a good thing for Frontier Labs
researchers also use it a lot
because researchers get to know a lot of things
which benchmarks are saturated
so on the basis of which they are able to find out new techniques
new ideas they come up with
basically people get a new research direction
policymakers and safety institutes
they also have a lot of stakes
they constantly monitor which models are operating at what level
is there any new model that is leaving everyone behind
so they have to come into the picture
they have to stop or they have to
basically they come in between and try to make changes
like what happened with Fable 5, US government came immediately
because they saw that this model is dangerous
and lastly the open source community
for that too leaderboards work very well
because with the help of leaderboards discovery happens
like I said that I myself am using leaderboards for discovery
there are many more people like me who go and search for
new models on leaderboards
there is a new research lab with 10-15 people
and they have released a new model
which scored very well on a single benchmark
and went to the top 3-4
so that lab's publicity became very famous
similarly they came in the picture
Chinese labs came in the picture
suddenly a new model came overnight
so its discovery, publicity, marketing
in that sense too LLM leaderboards are great
so I hope you understood this
what are leaderboards
why they exist and who takes their work
now let's discuss quickly
what are the different types of leaderboards that exist
so precisely there are 4 types of leaderboards
which you will get to see
the first and simplest leaderboard is
benchmark specific leaderboards
so here your leaderboard
creates a ranking on the basis of a single benchmark
it is written here
these rank models using the result of one particular benchmark
either it is MMLU or HumanEval
for coding or it is GSM8 for maths
or it is GPQ
so you will see all the models on a single benchmark
and that ranking will be shown in the form of a leaderboard
so the main idea is to tell which model
performs best on this benchmark
the only problem with this kind of leaderboard is
that they give you a very narrow view
how a model performs on a single benchmark
you just get to know this, how is the overall model
you don't get an idea about it, this is a very good example
I have shown you this
just one second
this is a zoom issue
I have shown you this
this is HLE's website
Humanities last exam
this is its leaderboard
Gemini 3 pro is at 38%
and it is showing calibration error
so this is a single benchmark
so most of the famous benchmarks have their own leaderboards
these research teams
make and maintain these leaderboards
on their own
these type of leaderboards are not very useful
this second category is useful
where you will read about multi benchmark leaderboards
from the name it is clear that these are such leaderboards
which together
bring the results of multiple benchmarks
and give a cumulative score
so it is written here
these leaderboards compare models across multiple benchmarks
and evaluation dimensions instead of relying on just one test
so it is possible that a leaderboard
which combines knowledge, reasoning, mathematics
coding, instruction following, data analysis
and makes a leaderboard by combining these benchmarks
I will show you an example
a good example of this is livebench
see it is written here
a challenging contamination free LLM benchmark
which has 23 objective tasks across 7 categories
reasoning, coding, agentic coding
how much score is there in every model
and an overall score is also shown
this is like a more useful leaderboard
because it gives you an overall view
of how a model is in general in multiple capabilities
I hope you understand
and not only this, these leaderboards
give you information on other aspects
like how much is the cost per token
how much is the latency, how much is the output speed
how much is the size of the context window
so I will show you an example of this
this is an artificial analysis company
they have a team to make leaderboards
and provide this kind of information
so they make leaderboards on all kinds of things
see they have a different leaderboard for intelligence
a different leaderboard for speed, cost per task
a different leaderboard
like it is a very exhaustive list
they have made HLE, GPQ, diamond separately
so these are the companies
which are basically making you all kinds of leaderboards
so they are like a proper product
they have a separate leaderboard for coding agents
speech, image, audio, hardware
so a lot of leaderboards are there
then they have made an overall by accumulating everything
so this is the most useful category
personally I use this the most and people use it the most
this type of leaderboards answer this question
which model provides the strongest overall combination of capability, cost and performance
this is the leaderboard that you will use the most
third is another interesting category
this is called human preference based leaderboards
in this you don't make a rank based on a benchmark
what you do is
you make a comparison
so your user comes to your website
you ask him a question
same question is asked by two models
A and B
both the answers are there
now you ask the user whether you liked A or B
so basically you are scoring yourself
on the basis of helpfulness, clarity, writing quality, creativity
and the way of giving the answer
and when a lot of these types of votes are collected
then a ranking is made on the basis of that
and that ranking is shown in this leaderboard
here it is written
these rank models using human votes
we took a response from two models, asked the user to select which one
and after a lot of votes
this leaderboard shows us which model is at the top
so this is a very famous example
LMLENA
in battle mode, you can ask anything
let's say we ask what are LMLENA leaderboards
now as soon as we run on this
so you see here two
let's refresh
what are LMLENA leaderboards
so now there are two models behind the scenes
I don't know which models are there
and they will give their answers
you can see
and once they will give their answers
I will read both and I will be asked
which one you liked the most
A is better, both are good, both are bad
B is better
now I have not read it
let's say I said B is better
so now it will reveal which one is it
this was Claude Opus 4.8 search and this was Fable
now by collecting votes from people all over the world
they make these leaderboards
so this is the current ranking
Fable 5, 5.6 soul, 4.8 thinking
and you can do this in different categories
you can do it in normal chat, the code is different
the image is different, the video is different
so this is also a type of leaderboard that exists
and is very famous
the limitation of this type
is that it is not necessary
that if a user feels an answer better
then the answer is really better
sometimes we humans get shocked
that they have given a good format
or they have given a little answer
which I like personally
so there is a little human bias
but again, it is at scale, people all over the world are doing it
then you can trust it and that is why you can see
that the top models are leading in these leaderboards
and the last type of leaderboards are
these are the leaderboards that are built around a particular domain
or work
like a dedicated coding leaderboard
so the benchmarks in coding
they made a single score
with the combination of all of them
and it is shown here
or you are making a separate leaderboard for agentic tasks
or you are making a separate leaderboard
or you are making a separate leaderboard for medical questions
so if I show you an example of this type
then this is a leaderboard
Berkeley functional calling leaderboard
so this is a leaderboard
which specifically tells
that the tool calling capacity of your model is
how good it is
so on the basis of that it ranks the models
so it is using multiple benchmarks
but in a single domain
so there are many of this type, there are different benchmarks for coding
so there are different benchmarks
so you will see these four types
the least useful is the single benchmark leaderboard
the most useful is the multiple benchmark
general capability measuring leaderboard
which tells you a lot of things, cost, latency, everything
human based is also popular
it is used a lot for marketing
which is the top on LM RNA
and the last one is that there are specific categories
of your application of the leaderboard
which you use if you are making an application of a particular domain
these are the four types of leaderboards
that you will find on internet
so let's read the rest
and then we will do the Q&A together
next thing, although leaderboards are very strong
and gives you a summarized overview
of the entire LLM landscape
but you cannot blindly trust leaderboards
this is very important
because you will work like AI engineers in the future
and most of the times when you go to make an application
then step one is model selection
and in model selection also step one is to go to the leaderboards
and see which model is at the top
so we get the bias that if it is on the leaderboard then it will be right
but it is not, you cannot blindly trust leaderboards
what are the reasons we are discussing
the first reason is that benchmark performance may not
transfer to real applications
this is very important
if a model is hitting 80-90
it does not mean that it will give you the same results
in your real application
like the famous thing that if you solve the problem on Kaggle
it does not mean that you will become a good data scientist in real life
why was it said like that?
because the data that is given on Kaggle is very clean
problem statement is very clear
generally you get easy work, everything is messy in real world
benchmark data is generally clean
and models will perform well on it
in real world there are many things like ambiguous requests
missing information, company specific data, tool failure
unusual edge cases
whether the model handles all these or not, we don't know
so yeah, this is the first reason
second, as we discussed
benchmarks are easily contaminated
if the model is contaminated, then their leaderboard score will be contaminated
and inflated, it will be seen more
so don't blindly trust
it is possible that the score shown on the leaderboard is genuine
but it is also possible that the model has memorized
or it already knew these kinds of questions
so you cannot trust blindly
after that, this is a very genuine problem
and people have started discussing this in the last 1-2 years
so it is very clear that models can be over optimized
for the leaderboard
sometimes a particular leaderboard becomes very popular
like LM Erina
it has become very popular that who is top on LM Erina
so now companies also see
that the most important thing is who is top on LM Erina
so we have to top
now who will top on LM Erina? who will make humans top
so we will format it in this way
we will give soft answers
we will give some shabby answers
so there are more chances that our model will be selected
so now they will feed this kind of data
in their training or fine tuning stages
so that rather than
perform well in actual capability
perform well in situations like LM Erina
so what will happen is that your model
will start scoring well on the leaderboard
but will not improve its real world capabilities
so here is a very famous law
Goodhart's law, it says
when a measure becomes a target
it becomes less useful as a measure
so if you start targeting a metric
we will improve this metric, suppose you are a car
so now in India people buy cars only with mileage
so now your whole engineering team is focusing
on how to improve the mileage
so the whole engineering will be around mileage
but the overall car will get spoiled
because you are not focusing on driving dynamics
0-100 in how much time it reaches
you are focusing only on mileage, so here it is written
that if you target a metric, then that metric
will not be good, so that has started happening nowadays
that companies are building models
so that they can top the leaderboards
but the actual performance will not be good
after that, this is also an important thing
especially for those leaderboards
which combine multiple benchmarks
and show you the results
now the problem there is that
which benchmarks are being included
which are being excluded, that is on the leaderboard
after that, how the scores are normalized
suppose we are calculating
an overall score of different capabilities
so we are not being told how much weightage
we are giving to every capability, so such things
are hidden and they can sometimes bother you
so whenever you are looking at a leaderboard
the more transparency there is, the better
the data about the leaderboard is
after that, in a leaderboard
small differences do not matter
like there are two models, one has a score of 84.3
and the other is 84.1
and this model came in 3rd position
and this one went in 5th position
but the difference was only of 0.2
so we don't understand that we should choose the 3rd one
we will not choose the 5th one for our application
but there is a good chance that both are very similar
and 5th would be better for your application
so sometimes we start focusing more
on which rank the models are on
so the rank bias is there
that is not a good thing, if the difference is less
then the models are of the same level
so in rank 20, there will be no difference between rank 1 and rank 25
one or two questions can be wrong for anyone
so that is the logic here
6th is human preference leaderboards have human biases
we have already discussed this, now LM arena is there
now the top model here does not necessarily mean
that it is objectively the top model
humans like long answers, more confident answers
better formatted answers, more entertaining answers
but it is possible that the best model
does not know all this
then it will fail in the human leaderboard ranking
so that is also a problem
and lastly leaderboard scores are stale, incomplete
and self-reported
now see this example, which one we discussed just now
I showed you humanity's last exam
now here Gemini 3 pro has 38.3
so the best models have not come here
where you can see Fable or 5.6
because they have not updated yet
just one second
so many times the leaderboards are not updated
the results of old model versions will be found
or the new model will not be found
or you will get the results of the discontinued model
so that is not a good thing
so why should we trust the company
because the company is putting its own results
so these are 6-7 reasons
why you don't trust blindly leaderboards
but you do it carefully
it is a useful thing but you cannot be blind
so now comes the last thing
that we have to discuss
if you are an AI engineer
and you are building an LLM based application
and your first job is to select a model
for that
so how will you read LLM leaderboards
so this is a guideline
which I will tell you quickly
before going on any leaderboard
first of all you have to clear these 4-5 things in your mind
what type of application are you making
how much latency do you need in that application
how much cost can you bear
what are the needs of your context
are there any deployment constraints
can I use general publicly available models
or I have to use an on-premise model
so write all these things clearly
if this becomes clear then you will not be biased
towards the rank 1 model
if I want to set up an on-premise
then obviously I cannot use Claude Fayble
then I will have to go towards open source
so that opens up my mind
in step 2 you will not blindly go to any leaderboard
you will go to the leaderboard which is related to your work
if you are making an agent
then you will go to an agent related leaderboard
if you are making a chatbot
then you will go to the leaderboard
because you are getting direct objective measurement of the chatting
if you are making a rag then you will go to MTB
this is actually the leaderboard of the ranking of the embedding models
you have to put an embedding model in the rag
there are budget constraints in your application
so you will probably go to the artificial analysis
or Vellum leaderboard
because here you get exact information
about the speed of the embedding models
and how much money is spent
so this is step 2, you go to the right leaderboard
after that read the leaderboard correctly
means you understand everything
what is being scored, how is it being scored
who has evaluated it, how much was the inference budget
is there any reasoning or not
when is the evaluation data set, how old is it
is it being updated, is a test set being maintained
or not
have the benchmarks been saturated or not
confidence interval, we discussed
if it is a small data set then how much is the confidence interval
has it been told or not, if not then
then two very close models are effectively the same
if the composite leaderboard is adding multiple benchmarks
and giving a score then what are the
values and weightage, you will analyze all this
here are just many pointers written but you get the idea
blindly there is a number, you don't have to trust it
you have to read the star mark below
like you will see the key definitions here
so you will read all this, you will read the frequently asked questions
so you will be in a better position to judge that leaderboard
and then on the basis of your criteria
you will shortlist the top 3 to 5 models
and when you have your 5 models
then comes your 5th and most important step
that you will run your own evaluation on it
on those 5 models
and those 5 models
when your own evaluation set will run
and the results that they will give, then you will get your top candidate
so here one line that you have to remember
this is the most important line that you have to take
from this session that leaderboards
are not a selection tool
leaderboards are a filtering tool
not a decision tool, meaning you don't go to leaderboard
and decide that I will use this model
to make my application, no that is a wrong strategy
you shortlist 4 to 5 top models
with the help of leaderboards and then
you run custom evals on all of them and pick one model
and then you pick one model for your application
I hope you are understanding and we will do that
in the next session, as I said that the next classes will be practical
so next session is all about how do you run
your custom evaluation on a given LLM
that we will learn in the next class
so whatever flow I have told you, you will practically do it in the next class
so yeah
let me know if you have any questions
we have done the benchmarks
it is not complete
but at least we have seen what happens conceptually
and we have done the leaderboards too
now we will do custom evals, once we have done custom evals
then we will move to
the custom evaluation evals where we will read rag evals
and agent evals
ok Aman, you will get it
we will make a list in the notes
any other question?
how will we evaluate, I mean which application
so we have planned that
we will make a
SQL query
generator
we have to make this application
we will assume this and then for this application
we will select the models
and then on it
we will run our custom eval
so this is the use case which we have finalized for the next class
I hope it is interesting
did you find the class boring?
was it boring?
as I said, the most important metric for me
is always
that was the class boring?
ok
there are not many people
there are just 16 people, so just like GPQA
not really sure about
the answer
theory, we didn't study anything else
there was no practical thing, it was all theory
so ok, I am here for
5 more minutes, if you have any other question
or if you have any other question not related to session
you can ask
if there is no question, you can leave the session
this is Reno's phone
hello
so I guess
there are no questions
ok guys, see you in the next session
how many lectures will be there in the series
what should we expect in August
so we have covered all the theory
now we have to do practical things
rag eval, agent eval, online eval
practically, these are the 3 things
safety evals
so August, I thought it will be in July
but it didn't happen
August hopefully will be enough
for this playlist
how to club things up together
like LLME evals, MCPs, deep agents
and understand this interagent common all
keep studying Aaman
everything will start to club up
it will start making sense
read independently
at least I feel this
when I check myself
is it clicking, are all things clubbing up
so I am able to answer questions
so don't be impatient
your mind will start to understand
how things start
connecting
sir, hi sir
how are you able to unmute
we keep settings
do you want to talk to someone
you can talk, if you can unmute
there is a feature to raise your hand
do that, if you want to ask anything
as we design enterprise
agent AI applications should we
evaluate vendor provided agent SDKs
such as github copilot SDK
how would you evaluate
entire SDKs
SDKs
it is difficult
you can do models
you can do harness
not really sure how do you
evaluate SDKs
if you have something around it
I meant considering those SDKs as part of design
not really
we are studying
here in a way
you can say that we are making our own products
based on LLMs
these are also SDKs
so
once the product is complete
they can evaluate it
but you as a customer can't
it is like that
you made a chart board
and gave it to your client
and it can't evaluate it
you have control, code
you have IP
evaluation will happen from inside
they often include a mature agent harness
with capabilities such as agent loops
tool orchestration, context management, structured tool use
planning, re-planning behavior and built in execution patterns
so my question was should we be designing our
harness from scratch or leverage these SDKs
at places
again it depends on a lot of things
where you are working, what is the requirement
what kind of tasks you want to solve
for that you want to build a harness
from scratch or you want to use
an existing solution
basically
the question that comes in other domains
is the same question, to buy or build
buy or build
so you are learning to build
any solution
depends on the situation
so most of the smaller tasks
will be solved by these kind of
SDKs in the future but very
custom situations and problems to solve
companies will make their own harnesses
and SDKs themselves
so again since I don't know where you are working and what is your day to day work
I won't be able to comment on that
but I guess you understand it's basically a decision buy vs build
deep learning YouTube playlist is enough or
should we go for some other material
no no that is a beginner level playlist
definitely read more than that
there are many more things in deep learning
ok ok Giresh
so any other question guys?
can you guide for same
and deep learning, these good institutes
MIT and Stanford
they have a playlist on deep learning
you can see them because once your base
is made after seeing 100 days of deep learning
then you can pursue that
it will look difficult
but if you read it you will understand
in the book
a good book is Deep Learning by Ian Goodfellow
yes that's the name Ian Goodfellow
it's a little more academic but there is a lot in it
so once the base is made explore more
there is no end to knowledge
I can say more in AI
if you have time, if you have interest
pursue more, if you feel you just have to do
according to work then 100 days of deep learning is enough
you can handle a lot of interview questions
80-85%
the top 10-15% questions you may not be able to do
ok guys
I will close the session
ok
bye, good night